[Musique]
le Commodore pas succulent Le Cameroun a de
la chance
ne me demandez pas pourquoi nous sommes un pays de
paix tout autour de nous c'est encore la guerre
et nous ne pouvons pas prétendre être meilleurs que
les autres
la République du Cameroun a été un
pays indépendant  depuis 1960
depuis lors, il n'y a pas eu de guerre civile pas d'
affrontements ethniques ou religieux majeurs pas de
rébellion pas de roucoulements violents et pas de famines
une circonstance inhabituelle pour ce
pays africain unique souvent entouré de
chaos en effet le Cameroun agit comme un refuge
de paix et de stabilité au milieu de  un
continent troublé
les nombreuses nationalités et
religions différentes qui existent au Cameroun
pourraient être une recette potentielle pour un
désastre
sa population de 20 millions n'est pas seulement
divisée entre francophones et
anglophones, mais comprend 200 groupes ethniques
assez différents et souvent
méfiants les uns envers les autres bien que le  la
religion principale du Cameroun est le
catholicisme il y a un grand nombre de
protestants musulmans et animistes qui se sont
autrefois battus les uns contre les autres les guerres
et les conflits au Nigeria voisin le
Tchad et la République centrafricaine
ont également déplacé des millions de réfugiés
ici faisant du Cameroun un pays complexe
à gouverner donc  comment cet
équilibre remarquable est-il maintenu et un
monde de plus en plus compétitif et conflictuel comment cette paix peut-elle durer cette
paix qui doit coexister entre tant de
groupes différents de personnes
[Musique]
nous voyons très peu d'exemples de rivalité ou
d'affrontements entre les églises et les mosquées ce
n'est pas le cas  existe vraiment c'est le Nord
qui rencontre parfois des problèmes
car l'Islam étant la
religion dominante a tendance à assimiler
tout le monde ne demande pas à
Vasily comme Casilla
John ne le fait pas vers 1800 l'islam est arrivé au
Cameroun du nord les
tribus nomades connues sous le nom de pôles ont envahi
et  terres colonisées des
plaines du nord jusqu'au plateau de l'Adamaoua
les animistes qui appartenaient principalement
aux tribus Kerdi ont fui vers la
chaîne de montagnes Mandara où ils ont continué à
vivre et à maintenir des croyances et des
traditions anciennes remarquablement ces montagnes sèches et
inhospitalières ont été sculptées en
terrasses  Afin de cultiver des céréales
telles que la minute et le sorgho,
c'est étonnamment l'une des zones les plus peuplées du Cameroun
car les terres et les espaces de vie
sont devenus de plus en plus rares, certains Kerdi
ont commencé à migrer vers les plaines pour
s'installer parmi les
éleveurs convertis à
l'islam par le  piscines ou parmi les agriculteurs
qui ont été convertis au christianisme par
des missionnaires européens de violents combats
ont éclaté entre chrétiens et
musulmans dans les provinces du nord du
Nigeria depuis l'établissement des
lois musulmanes qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour le
Cameroun voisin,
la violence pourrait-elle se propager à travers la
frontière Sulli a 45 ans marié  et a 10
enfants et travaille comme chauffeur il est
musulman pratiquant si parfois Noël
et le ramadan se déroulent le même jour
cela ne cause probablement pas Noël je
vais chez les chrétiens parmi je mange je
bois pendant le ramadan les chrétiens viennent chez
moi  manger et boire ce n'est pas un problème
c'est le même Dieu c'est peut-être des pièces d'identité mm dia
certains de mes enfants ont décidé de devenir
chrétiens trois d'entre eux vont à l'église je
n'ai pas de problème avec ça je vis
avec eux en Corée c'est bien si votre
le cœur est blanc tu iras à un gentil
merci avec le poumon climatisé
Sybil
mais si ton comportement est mauvais tu vas
directement dans le verre à feu seul le
climat de Sombra est un to to to me pour parcourir un
mile jusqu'au Montana pour le nord de
Le Cameroun est toujours gouverné par environ 50
seigneurs musulmans traditionnels connus sous le nom de la
Meadows le seigneur le plus puissant la
lamina de mayo ray règne sur un
territoire aussi grand que la Belgique depuis son
palais dans une petite ville de rabbu bar il
perçoit les impôts de tous ses sujets
nomme village  les chefs résolvent les
conflits locaux et sont chargés de
rendre la justice en perpétuant les
pratiques séculaires d'un système féodal et
patriarcal les femmes doivent être
seins nus pour entrer dans son palais et
les sujets s'inclinent devant
lui car ils ne sont pas autorisés à regarder
directement  dans ses yeux
[Musique]
comment les sujets chrétiens de ce
roi traditionnel vivent-ils sous un tel
système de souveraineté sach J est un petit
village à prédominance chrétienne avec
à peine quatre mille habitants un nombre
qui a doublé avec l'arrivée récente
d'immigrants qui n'étaient  élevé dans la
foi chrétienne, cependant, pour
devenir chef de village, il a dû se convertir
à l'islam en se résolvant à fréquenter régulièrement
la minuscule mosquée du village. de nombreuses
familles camerounaises ont des membres de
différentes religions, comme le cas de
Joseph et de son père, tous deux
luthériens mariés à des musulmans ici  les
chrétiens et les musulmans que nous vivons ensemble
il n'y a pas de quartier musulman ou de
quartier chrétien la fête musulmane que
j'aime le plus est la fête du mouton
ils préparent beaucoup de couscous et
le distribuent à tout le monde donc si vous êtes
chrétien ou musulman  vous êtes invité à
démoniaquement Kony à la seule émotion ici
les enfants suivent généralement la religion de
leurs pères quand ma fille grandit
elle choisira entre la foi de son père
et la mienne
mon mari dit les bonnes choses à mes
parents je deviendrai chrétien
sinon je resterai musulmane maintenant sa
famille ne la rejetterait pas, disent-ils
puisque votre mari est chrétien, vous devez
suivre le même chemin en ce moment, elle peut
chanter plus de versets bibliques que moi, elle a
également mémorisé lorsque vous atteignez un
certain âge vous  je suis assez instruit pour
changer pour dire non mon père est
chrétien mais je veux être musulman
parce que les musulmans vont à La Mecque je peux gagner
beaucoup d'argent vraiment c'est l'argent qui
fait que les gens se convertissent à l'islam parce que les
hommes musulmans sont respectés de l'autre
part les chrétiens ne sont pas vraiment respectés
je croirai en Allah de tout mon
cœur pour l'éternité la grande différence est que
les musulmans croient en Mohammed
personnellement je ne crois pas qu'il soit un vrai
prophète nous les chrétiens croyons en Jésus
qui est un vrai prophète dans le sac Jay  l'
église évangélique luthérienne est une simple
hutte en argile les pâtes s'occupent de plusieurs
villages et ne viennent pas régulièrement à
l'église une partie du toit s'est
effondrée et les dons des croyants
ne suffiront pas pour les réparations
comment éviteront-ils les dommages futurs des
pluies torrentielles pendant la  prochaine
saison des pluies parce que les églises protestantes ont
demandé l'indépendance de leurs
églises sœurs allemandes, norvégiennes et américaines,
le financement est devenu un problème pour
les paroisses de brousse
[Musique]
il y a six autres églises chrétiennes
dans le sac J dont la plupart ont été construites par des
migrants arrivant de différentes
confessions la situation est tout aussi
troublante avec les évangélistes unifiés les
églises adventistes et catholiques romaines
sont faites de paille avec des bancs de fortune
et les prêtres et ministres sont rarement
présents malgré cela la foi des croyants
reste forte et sincère nos familles
sont essentiellement des familles de
religions mixtes même ici dans le sud  du
pays notre famille notre famille ma famille
une famille nombreuse est composée de musulmans
protestants et catholiques tandis que les musulmans
détiennent l'essentiel du pouvoir politique dans le
nord les chrétiens contrôlent le
sud alors qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour la
minorité musulmane du sud mrs.  Bello
a quitté sa famille dans le nord pour
s'installer à Douala la ville natale de son
mari musulman elle gère le centre d'affaires
dans un grand hôtel
je ne suis pas discriminé nous n'avons pas
ce genre de problèmes dans ce
pays je me sens aussi à l'aise que  Je fais
de retour à la maison par exemple je garde mon tapis de prière
au bureau mon tapis peut être donc à
n'importe quel moment pendant les heures de prière je peux
sortir et prier si la religion musulmane
était pratiquée comme il a été décrété la
femme serait une déesse regarde  le
coran dit adore ta mère
respecte ton père cela veut dire que la
femme a un rôle central mrs.  Bello et
son mari ont élevé leurs enfants en tant que
musulmans dans un pays de chrétiens comment
leurs enfants ressentent-ils leurs
différences par rapport aux autres sont-ils
gênés quand ils prient Allah
ils trouvent cela normal ils nous ont vu jouer
depuis qu'ils étaient très jeunes alors  ça ne
les surprend pas c'est le plus jeune qui
posait souvent des questions sur ses copains
à l'école et on leur expliquait que les autres
sont différents d'eux mais ce
n'est pas une raison pour les détester ils doivent
accepter des élèves de religions différentes
sinon ils n'auraient pas d'amis  il y
a des intégristes partout
même ici il y en a qui n'acceptent pas
les autres il faut s'efforcer de
s'entendre car l'islam est avant
tout une religion de tolérance dans la
capitale yaoundé l'arabie saoudite a
commandé une grande mosquée bonne
fréquentation en période de  La prière
ne signifie pas nécessairement que les gens
prêtent attention à la prédication des
préceptes islamiques des musulmans de la charia
au Cameroun comprennent en fait
mieux le français que l'arabe, il est peut-être
surprenant qu'il y ait tant de
tolérance entre les personnes de tant de
confessions différentes dans un  un pays comme le
Cameroun en effet sur une colline face à la
mosquée un Centre Catholique a été construit
par un prêtre particulièrement dynamique le
Révérend John Mary Buddha a affronté
le monopole de la radio d'état en créant la
première radio privée du Cameroun
un projet qu'il a commencé en 1997 aujourd'hui l'
église doit  revendiquer sa revendication dans les médias
parce que les médias sont un outil important
donc j'ai rencontré l'évêque et
lui ai dit de lancer une station de radio catholique
il a essayé mais il n'a pas pu obtenir le financement
et s'est découragé alors j'ai dit d'accord j'essaierai
de  le faire moi-même et nous n'avons pas
attendu l'autorisation du gouvernement, ils
étaient prêts à nous laisser diffuser, alors nous avons
dit ici que nous travaillons pour le bien
des gens,
je veux dire dans des bureaux à travers la ville à certains
moments, presque tout le monde arrête de travailler par
exemple  pour la prière du chapelet du Seigneur dans
les ministères les écoles de l'ambassade les
écoles primaires et secondaires partout les gens
écoutent la prière de 30 minutes c'est une
radio chrétienne pour les citoyens cela signifie que
nous sommes chrétiens et que nous avons une présence
dans le monde nous devons nous définir
par rapport à la politique  et à l'
économie ainsi qu'en relation avec les
problèmes de développement en dehors de la création de
partenariats clés avec radio Vatican à
Rome et radio not Road am à Paris Le
révérend boda était également un ami proche du
pape Jean-Paul II d'où il porte
le nom de son nouvel auditorium  l'
auditorium est le site de conventions
et de concerts ainsi que de messes télévisées
ce prêtre passionné et motivé envisage
de créer une chaîne de télévision chrétienne privée
et une clinique de santé pour
les enfants sans abri les gens peuvent penser oh il a
beaucoup d'argent c'est comme ça qu'il peut tout faire
cela mais ceux qui travaillent avec moi savent que je
n'ai pas l'argent que nous avons réussi à
réussir parce que j'y crois vraiment j'y
mets toute mon énergie et ma confiance la
majorité des camerounais sont de vrais
croyants qui assistent régulièrement aux offices religieux
ou prient dans le  La mosquée pourrait-elle que le
leadership religieux soit la clé pour
comprendre la paix et l'harmonie
entre les nombreux groupes différents que
recherchent exactement les Camerounais dans la religion, le révérend père
Hebdo a créé le fr Tom, un groupe de prière qui
a acquis une énorme influence
à travers le Cameroun et même en  la
Côte d'Ivoire en France ses enseignements sont
diffusés régulièrement à
la télévision nationale camerounaise et ses messes attirent de grandes
foules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si nos deux disciples sont témoins de
guérisons spectaculaires par la prière collective l'
amour de Jésus et le partage de la messe est
presque terminé lorsqu'une jeune femme à l'
arrière s'effondre au sol
handicapés
donnez nous une photo faite
comme l'utilisation de dimanche contre le peuple a dit
que vous avez fait des chansons du
marché immobilier de silicium de la santé mentale des ténèbres pour soutenir
la guérison a été effectuée par un
berger du groupe de prière
la jeune femme retrouve ses sens il
invoque le Seigneur avec sa croix et le
public pour le voir  a demandé au public d'
invoquer le Seigneur le seul Sanctus
le seul Dieu le seul Seigneur qui peut
nous libérer et quand il dit ces mots quelqu'un
peut réellement se lever et entrer en
transe nous savons tout de suite que c'est
la personne possédée le révérend egg meurt
non  plus le serviteur de jésus mais ses
amis car Jésus lui a donné un grand
pouvoir et il s'en sert extrêmement bien il
soigne les malades sur ce qu'on appelle des
petits démons qui arrivent et n'ont plus de
force
le Révérend les écrase par la prière
car il a vécu avec  Jésus-Christ est
maintenant à l'écoute des commandements de Dieu
j'ai écouté les conseils des prêtres cela
me donne une foi infatigable en Dieu parce que
je crois en lui et cela me met dans un
état d'extase ma vie n'est remplie que
du Christ nous prions souvent depuis  19h  à
7 heures du matin oui et les gens sont enthousiastes
jusqu'au bout je veux dire ici à colleton
même quand il pleut comme mercredi dernier
il y avait 1000 à 1500 personnes et ils
ne sont pas partis je t'appartiens j'appartiens à
Jésus j'appartiens à mon Sauveur et puis  le
public qui peut trouver des hauts
fonctionnaires tels que des épouses de ministres qui
n'ont pas peur de montrer leur foi
père hep cos les guérisons et les exorcismes
sont influencés par les croyances animistes dans les
villages profonds des forêts tropicales du
sud du Cameroun des cérémonies de délivrance
ressemblant au vaudou sont régulièrement organisées
telles  comme ici près de la ville d'Eber plus bas
ces pratiques viennent du
Gabon et du Congo voisins
depuis la nuit des temps les camerounais ont
peur de la possession démoniaque et de l'
influence spirituelle néfaste des ancêtres le
sorcier utilise l'iboga une
substance hallucinogène trouvée dans l'écorce des arbres qui
soi-disant combat le mal et  l'aide à
communiquer avec les esprits ancestraux l'iboga
provient d'une espèce rare d'arbre trouvée au
plus profond des jungles d'Afrique
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
le diable a envahi le monde nous sommes
ici pour sauver ceux qui sont des désastres alors
quand nous les libérons mal ça  signifie que
l'esprit sain en eux est toujours
là et que le monde religieux
existe toujours à travers le chant et le tambour les
patients sont lentement bercés dans une transe
qui vise à se libérer de la
possession parmi les différents rituels
la cérémonie d'inhumation est fréquemment
effectuée mais le principe de  ce
rituel pour reprendre possession de son
âme par une mort symbolique partage des
similitudes avec les croyances chrétiennes du
renouveau et de la renaissance le but de l'utilisation d'
Avoca est de ramener l'esprit divin
car l'esprit naturel est sur le point de mourir
voici sa fonction de rendre le patient
réagir lorsque l'esprit maléfique est sur le point de
prendre le relais et de contrôler le patient dovey
boga est nécessaire pour écraser cet esprit
ne peut pas voir après avoir passé une heure 6 pieds
sous terre dans l'obscurité totale et
avec très peu d'oxygène le patient est
sorti de la tombe et
symboliquement ressuscités par le sorcier
de nombreux chrétiens consultent des sorciers iboga
parfois en dernier recours les
patients les plus malades les plus fortement
possédés comme il le dit doivent rester chez le
médecin à l'écart des forces maléfiques
qui ont envahi le domicile du patient des
rituels et traitements répétés sont
nécessaires  pour libérer le patient et
guérir leur âme, de nombreux Camerounais
croient encore que les guérisseurs traditionnels peuvent guérir un
large éventail de problèmes, même des
maladies mortelles, cela explique pourquoi tant de personnes ici
considèrent encore le sida comme un sortilège et certains
sorciers sont censés libérer
le corps du mortel  virus
médecine de l'âme délivrance du corps et ceux qui
sont capables de parler avec les ancêtres sont
considérés comme puissants par beaucoup au Cameroun
ils sont le lien entre les
mondes spirituel et matériel
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand le patient découvre la vérité le
patient est  libre d'aller à l'église ou de
venir me voir parce que le patient veut
être guéri et veut connaître le vrai
guérisseur depuis des lustres les gens en Afrique
sont convaincus que les forces du mal existent
et que ces forces ont du pouvoir sur
eux les gens peuvent se moquer d'eux les missionnaires
peuvent  dites-leur oh c'est de
la superstition païenne c'est irrationnel mais ça
n'a aucun effet sur eux les gens sont dans
l'angoisse l'
animisme n'a pas disparu au Cameroun
il se cache simplement derrière d'autres
religions plus respectables socialement comme
le christianisme ou l'islam l'animisme est
particulièrement répandu chez les Kerdi
au  nord du Cameroun
[Musique]
chaque sorcier de Kerdi a sa propre
technique ce docteur particulier utilise
des crabes qui sont censés agir comme la
main de Dieu en déplaçant de petites pierres rondes
à l'intérieur d'un pot couvert la position finale
des pierres l'aide à prédire l'
avenir lui permettant  pour conseiller ses
clients sur un plan d'action, il y a
quelque chose comme une invasion d'églises
et d'appels les gens ont du mal à gagner
leur vie à se faire soigner et
à trouver un emploi et toutes les différentes
sectes leur promettent la lune maintenant il y
a des centaines de sectes secrètes  les gens
diront tout de suite si vous voulez obtenir un emploi,
rejoignez une telle secte ou une telle société secrète,
cela arrive même à l'université,
ils sont comme des clubs, certains pratiquent
le satanisme dans ce pays, on m'a raconté
des histoires incroyables de filles qui
entrent dans  le cimetière la nuit pour invoquer
Satan et demander un mari ou une belle
voiture ils rentrent sans rien ils ne
reçoivent ni mari ni voiture et ils ont perdu
leur capacité de parler en grandit
comme jamais auparavant
il y a d'innombrables jeunes hommes qui sont
prêts à devenir prêtres  le vatican a même
dit de ralentir qu'on gagne
trop de prêtres un an l'archevêque
a annoncé vingt nouveaux prêtres nous
avions déjà seize seize c'est beaucoup pour
un an dans un diocèse
que recherchent les jeunes camerounais
aujourd'hui dans le rang de l'église catholique
reconnaissance sur les contreforts du Mont
Cameroun se trouve Thole un village de la
partie anglophone du pays
Thole est un quartier défavorisé
où policiers et médecins prennent rarement le
risque de venir ici
Jeannot pondre un jeune séminariste
termine son noviciat pour utiliser la
source principale  de revenus ici les gens viennent
travailler dans les plantations de thé ça attire
surtout des gens du nord-ouest qui
viennent gagner de l'argent sur la plantation qui
paye à peine les gens sont encore très pauvres
et
des conditions insalubres le village est
peuplé de migrants de différentes
tribus et villages mais ici vous ne
trouverez pas le célèbre sens de la
solidarité et de la communauté africaine malgré cela un
groupe de jeunes tente de
changer les choses mon supérieur nous a demandé de
prendre soin de la  jeunes, nous avons pu nous
impliquer dans un groupe appelé las
vegas, nous travaillons avec eux depuis
cinq mois maintenant ici, ils cultivent principalement du
maïs, mais il y a aussi quelques bananiers,
des plantains, des avocats et d'autres cultures que nous avons
vraiment remarquées beaucoup plus  partage et
camaraderie si un membre du groupe ou un voisin
est malade tout le groupe est informé et
on essaie de voir ce qu'on peut faire ensemble pour
aider la personne
et éviter qu'elle ne se sente
isolée
[Musique]
J'ai moi-même fait face à la souffrance et
la pauvreté une sœur catholique m'a aidée
matériellement et avec mon éducation j'ai
réalisé que c'est mieux pour moi de
donner ma vie aux autres il y a
trop de mes frères africains qui souffrent
quand les gens font face à des difficultés extrêmes cela
peut briser leur foi et les amener
à  le doute par contre avoir à faire
face à des difficultés peut les aider à s'ouvrir
au Seigneur je connais une femme de 27 ans
qui a commencé à douter de sa foi
suite à de nombreux fardeaux
pourquoi Dieu accepte que certaines choses
m'arrivent je vais à l'église  Je fais ce que
le prêtre dit mais rien ne va mieux
alors nous avons commencé à parler et avons décidé de nous
rencontrer de temps en temps tout d'abord Dieu
n'est pas un magicien
ensuite il y a probablement
des responsabilités dont elle doit s'occuper
pour résoudre ses problèmes
qu'elle ne devrait pas négliger  cette troisième, elle
ne devrait pas abandonner, elle devrait prendre le
contrôle de sa vie, travailler sur ses problèmes
et passer à autre chose
partage généralement son expérience avec
sept autres étudiants camerounais et mensonge du
séminaire Geryon qui travaillent dans
la congrégation San Vincent DePaul, ils travaillent
avec des adultes et des enfants malades  Je sens que
j'en profite, est-ce que je trouve que
c'est ce que je veux faire dans la vie oui
définitivement
mon travail ici m'apporte le bonheur et me
fait me sentir complet et sinon je grandis
dans la vie et me permet d'entrer dans une relation plus profonde
avec Dieu  et avec d'autres
ainsi que de travailler dans les
domaines communautaires Ginola a encouragé le groupe
à écrire et mettre en scène une pièce traitant du
SIDA
un adulte sur huit au Cameroun est
séropositif les pratiques dangereuses qui
peuvent propager le SIDA sont soulignées dans la
pièce qu'elle a été jouée  plusieurs fois
et a été vu par de nombreuses personnes à Tony
cela a bien fonctionné pour faire passer le message
du VIH et du SIDA aux gens la
meilleure façon de prévenir le SIDA est l'abstinence la
patience et l'attente du bon moment
il vaut mieux ne pas se précipiter dans quoi que ce soit
le  L'Église catholique est contre
les contraceptifs et les préservatifs
au lieu de cela, elle met en avant la loyauté et ainsi de suite
ici à Cameron d8 les protestants
ont adopté une position différente en faisant valoir
que personne ne reste vraiment fidèle aux
meilleures femmes devant les tribunaux si nous condamnons
les préservatifs, nous nous dirigeons droit vers un désastre au
Cameroun  la religion joue un
rôle spirituel social et éducatif de plus en plus important une situation
qui pose la question de savoir comment ces
confessions sont financées et maintenues l'islam
est soutenu par les pays arabes
notamment la Libye et l'Arabie Saoudite les
catholiques reçoivent des fonds de redistribution
de Rome
pour les églises protestantes mais le financement
est plus problématique  la fréquentation
augmentant plus vite que les dons n'arrivent
[Musique] Les
presbytériens du Cameroun comptent
entièrement sur la générosité de leurs
paroissiens, un aperçu révélateur de la raison pour laquelle
les ministres presbytériens recherchent de grandes
paroisses urbaines comme celle-ci à Messer,
un quartier aisé le
dimanche matin jusqu'à  2 000 personnes
assistent au service très animé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Musique]
peu amusant une nouvelle église indépendante a
dû s'organiser très rapidement la
pensée puisque nous n'avions pas de financement dont
nous devions nous occuper  tout par nous
même pas de problème là où l'église ici a
été construite grâce aux
dons des paroissiens nous fournissons le matériel de construction
et la main d'oeuvre quand tu aimes le
Christ et tout ce qui l'implique tu
te donnes entièrement car tu sais
que ta foi t'apportera la
vie éternelle comme  une récompense quand ils savent qu'ils
travaillent pour le bien de la
communauté
les croyants n'hésitent pas à donner
il y a toujours des moutons noirs qui se plaignent
nous sommes pauvres on ne peut pas donner on n'a rien
mais la foi ce n'est pas être une
foi passive  il s'agit de se donner J'ai
toujours dit à ma congrégation que tant
qu'ils croient qu'ils devraient être actifs dans
cette croyance, un chrétien n'est pas celui qui
s'assoit les bras croisés en attendant que
les richesses du ciel lui tombent dessus non
nous devons combattre la vie  est une lutte et
tant que nous sommes en vie nous luttons tant que
nous recherchons la gloire c'est le
problème de
rechercher la gloire au lieu de la paix le
Seigneur a dit gloire à Dieu et paix aux hommes
mais les hommes ont déformé cela en que la paix
soit avec Dieu  et gloire aux hommes ce n'est pas
comme ça qu'au Cameroun mais aussi en
Europe dans les
grandes villes du Cameroun il ne
faut pas longtemps pour voyager du
quartier aisé au quartier le plus pauvre
voila la capitale économique du Cameroun
abrite 3 millions de personnes qui luttent
pour  gagner leur vie la population mondiale
a augmenté plus vite que sa richesse dans
ce village devenu une ville dure les gens ont
désespérément besoin de valeurs et d'un sens d'
où ils viennent les traditions et le
sens de la communauté renommé de l'Afrique
s'estompent les enfants sont les premiers à souffrir
de l'aggravation de la vie
conditions 15 000 enfants vivent maintenant dans
la rue des centaines meurent dans la rue
chaque année et des milliers d'autres
deviennent sans abri lorsqu'ils vivent seuls dans
la rue il est facile de perdre le contact perdre la
foi et se sentir abandonné par Dieu
en 1996 une religieuse catholique de 75 ans a
ouvert 6 refuges  comme celui-ci pour héberger
300 enfants sans abri avec l'espoir de
leur donner un avenir meilleur dans la société
Moïse un jeune go était l'un de ces
enfants aujourd'hui grâce au refuge de soeur Mary
il travaille comme apprenti dans une
boulangerie il aide aussi les enfants c'est la
soeur Mary's à  s'habituer à
vivre au refuge c'est bon il
n'y a pas de problème vous attendez de la nourriture avez-
vous faim
les premières nuits au refuge sont
les plus difficiles les enfants perdent leur
sens de l'indépendance et doivent apprendre
à vivre avec les autres et à accepter le
refuge  règles le refuge travaille en
collaboration avec le Cirque du Soleil une
organisation qui aide
les enfants sans abri à se sentir en confiance tout en
les motivant à apprendre les activités du cirque
[Musique] [
Musique] les
conditions de vie dans les refuges sont dures le
manque d'intimité et les vols sont fréquents
cela peut aussi  être difficile pour
les enfants de devenir apprentis ou de
retourner à l'école donc beaucoup d'entre eux se retrouvent
dans la rue où ils devront
voler pour manger de la drogue pour bloquer la
réalité de leur situation aujourd'hui tu peux
être quelqu'un que tu es comme un  batterie j'ai été
poignardé à la jambe avec un couteau c'est
mon pire souvenir tu sais que
l'argent est si important ici tu
ne reçois pas l'aide des gens pour rien tu
dois leur donner quelque chose quand tu
aides quelqu'un tu attends quelque chose en
retour les gens ne le sont pas  trop dans le travail social
ce qui compte c'est l'argent mais il
faut lutter contre ça sinon
on va pas évoluer si tu es
admis dans un hôpital et que tu n'as pas d'
argent tu risques de mourir car personne ne
va s'occuper de toi mais si tu  donne
20 $ à un médecin oh il va
vraiment bien s'occuper de toi jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve un
remède maman avait du mal nous vivions dans un
appartement d'une pièce à l'époque / moi et mes
frères il n'y avait pas de place pour moi là-bas
je devais me débrouiller  sur mes propres
enfants dans la rue voir et ils ont fumé de
la marijuana
Moïse retourne parfois au ghetto c'est
dans la zone près du port où il a
vécu sa vie de délinquant et a
échappé de justesse à la mort il a souvent passé ses
nuits sur cette plateforme surnommée le
Pentagone par  les enfants tous les matins on
se lève on traverse le mur et on monte on monte dans
le bus on gère on
récupère des trucs on ne détruit
rien car ce sont nos biens on
récupère juste ce qu'on voit
[Musique]
c'est ici que  Moïse rêvait de
devenir marin et de parcourir l'
océan en vivant dans la rue, mais
ce rêve semblait presque impossible
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé à vivre dans la rue, j'ai
rencontré le Seigneur, je l'ai vu, il est venu me voir
dans mon sommeil, il m'a dit que  il fallait que je
devienne un homme qu'il fallait que je change de
vie que tout était possible pour moi
oui que je n'ai confiance qu'en lui que je
ne devais pas douter de lui bienvenue dans mon monde
Me voilà mon lit au refuge on va se
battre c'est ici  que je m'occupe de mes
galères et ici que je passe mes
nuits parfois dans la paix et parfois
dans la violence mais je m'en sors toujours
grâce à ça mes livres de prières ils
m'aident à aborder la vie ici c'est mon
globe c'est important pour les navigateurs ça
me permet de repérer les côtes  et
détroit
Pepa désolé apprécie le corps de kuta c'est
comme à la maison j'ai un lit je me sens à
l'aise tout le monde n'est pas aussi chanceux que
moi ce qui compte c'est la volonté vous pouvez
avoir de la chance mais si vous ne l'utilisez pas correctement
tout ira mal presque
tous les dimanches soirs, Moïse assiste à la messe
avec ses amis à l'église catholique be Pender
[Musique]
Moïse a économisé le salaire qu'il a reçu
de son apprentissage pour payer sa
formation de marin mais est encore
loin de son premier emploi sur un bateau qu'il a
cependant  a retrouvé sa confiance et
a un nouveau sens de l'espoir
grâce à une détermination sans faille
mais quels sont les autres enfants du
refuge
je ne vais pas à l'église parce que soeur Mary
me dit - tu m'as menti plus je vais
à l'église c'est parce que  Je veux c'est
parce que j'aime Jésus parce que je
lis la Bible et je suis ému par tout ce que
la Bible nous dit Je préfère rester ici
Je préfère demander pardon à Dieu dans
mon cœur plutôt que d'aller à l'église pour
montrer aux gens que je prie  il vaut mieux
être honnête avec soi-même de ne pas y aller
parce que tu vois d'autres personnes y aller quand
ton cœur n'y est pas tu ne fais
qu'imiter les autres s'il te plait dis positivement
Nikki déclare l'accent sur bizarrement c'est
vrai que parce que l'église est
partout elle connaît mieux ce pays
que  quelqu'un d'autre par exemple pour vivre dans
cette ville tous les week-ends l'
évêque axillaire et moi allons dans les
paroisses du quartier nous passons les soirées à écouter les
gens aujourd'hui même si nous ne sommes pas en
guerre donc je sais que beaucoup de camerounais
ressentent des tensions en eux les gens
sont prêts à se battre pour n'importe quoi voir
des copains par exemple si quelqu'un a
un peu heurté la voiture de quelqu'un d'autre l'autre
personne veut immédiatement se battre pour
ça
veloute oui paire j'espère que les gens qui
dirigent ce pays vont être
prudents car il y a des juges
dans ce  pays les droits fondamentaux
qui ne sont pas respectés
[Musique]
Prêtre dominicain Elwha Messi Motoko
journalistes et professeur de théologie
enseigne à l'Université catholique de donde
il a une opinion critique de son pays
et du rôle de l'église dont l'église
a besoin pour aller à la racine du  problème
pour dénoncer plus courageusement les
systèmes politiques de l'Afrique car d'une certaine manière ces
systèmes entretiennent la pauvreté et l'insécurité
je sais que des lettres très fortes
de l'église ont été écrites mais
malgré celles-ci chaque évêque ne lui
plaît pas il peut signer une lettre persuasive
le matin  devenir la nuit, il
porte un toast au champagne avec l'un des
ministres un acte qui contredit ce qu'il
a écrit dans la lettre de plus
ces lettres ne sont pas assez distribuées la
plupart des gens ne les lisent pas certains prêtres
ne les lisent même pas comment pouvez-vous vous attendre à ce
que le public  lisez-les communautés ils
doivent également être traduits dans les
langues africaines que les gens comprennent que
les gens ont besoin d'un peu plus d'âme quand je vois
ce qui se passe là-bas pourquoi n'ai-je pas
eu l'impression que nous reculons
les gens tuent sans arrière-pensée
c'est sérieux  certaines personnes disent que
les Africains respectent la vie, j'ai cessé de
croire qu'il y a longtemps, une fois que vous
faites cela, les gens ne prennent pas
des emplois ou des postes gouvernementaux et
des entreprises et de l'administration pour des
raisons égoïstes pour gagner de l'argent pour accumuler des
richesses personnelles, ils obtiennent ce qu'ils veulent
et ne le font pas  ne pas se préoccuper des
problèmes de société c'est ce contre quoi nous devons
lutter mais il n'y a personne pour
contrôler la façon dont les choses sont gérées dans
les entreprises
donc la corruption est répandue un
en tant que votre patron je peux décider de prendre 20% de
votre salaire vous ne pouvez pas  plaignez-vous vous
l'acceptez vous n'avez pas de salaire vous
voyez pourquoi on voudrait devenir
évêque c'est une bonne question beaucoup de
prêtres qui veulent devenir évêques bien
sûr st.  Paul a écrit qu'il est positif
d'aspirer à devenir évêque mais je ne
pense pas qu'il serait d'accord avec les raisons que
les gens ont maintenant de vouloir être
évêques, ils oublient que nous sommes appelés
à prendre soin de l'église, cela devient
de plus en plus personnel  affaires pourquoi
à cause des honneurs associés au fait
d'être évêque et de l'argent, il y a
des prêtres qui ont été condamnés pour
détournement de fonds, cela montre simplement que
l'église n'est pas isolée de la société
mais qu'elle devra changer si elle veut
faire partie de la société  je suis dora city
avant que les cercles de kelly soient en automne sur la
zone insulaire
les gens à
agir en tant que témoins de la foi c'est pourquoi
l'université n'est pas seulement ouverte aux
séminaristes-- mais aussi au grand
public un avenir marrons repose sur la
nouvelle génération une génération qui
fréquente encore les universités les lycées et les
écoles élémentaires l'harmonie qui
existe entre  les religions et les ethnies
sont menacées l'équilibre de cette jeune
nation est encore assez fragile aujourd'hui les
camerounais subissent les
pressions et les conséquences de la vie dans
une société de plus en plus urbaine et
individualiste où la pauvreté est
en hausse
mais ils restent tolérants envers les autres avec
un sentiment de fierté  dans leur pays un
optimisme quant à son potentiel mais si
les conditions de vie venaient à se détériorer et que la course au
pouvoir politique s'arrêtait
les Camerounais pourraient perdre
patience et le pays pacifique pourrait
facilement basculer dans la rébellion et la violence
le peuple camerounais a perdu une partie de
le rêve que leur ont apporté l'indépendance et vingt
ans de croissance économique rapide ne
leur reste aujourd'hui que
la force de leurs prières et
la sincérité de leur foi même si vous me
priez mille fois par jour ne devenez pas
dur c'est noir lui même  ou si ce n'est pas
où suis-je super
[Musique]
pour me réveiller chaque matin et prier c'est une
bonne façon de commencer la journée ne penses-tu pas que
toute la journée tu te sens bien tu
ressens la paix en toi Dieu Tout-Puissant tu as
donné au monde  à l'homme tu ne voulais pas
finir la création mais par la confiance que tu as
donnée à l'homme tu lui as permis de
continuer ta création pour moi prier c'est
demander pardon c'est demander
de l'aide à Dieu quand je demande quelque chose à Dieu je
ne comprends pas  loin mais plus tard pour moi avoir la
foi c'est remettre sa vie à
Jésus ma foi ne m'amène pas aux
autres si elle n'appelle pas mon amour pour
les autres alors cette foi ne m'intéresse pas
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]